say good morning to peacock who carries
the program also carries
pro football talk live with the popular
mike florio
and chris sims every morning monday
through friday preceding our show and
mike kind enough to join us
what did the raiders do wrong and did it
warrant that kind of punishment
well dan it all flows from the trent
brown
positive test that was followed by trent
brown
not wearing a contact tracing device
which is one of the key mechanisms for
determining
who was exposed to a player who
eventually test positive that was part
of it
and it was an accumulation of the
various things we've seen the raiders
punished for from john gruden not
wearing a mask that was
350 000 in total fines an unauthorized
person in the locker room that was
another 50
000 fine the event where
several players were present in a
confined space with too many people and
no masks in sight
players were fined for that so this is
that system of progressive discipline
the nfl
uses when the first effort doesn't take
they hit you a little harder the next
time and they'll keep hitting you harder
and harder so this time
650 000 in fines a sixth round draft
pick goes away
and if they don't straighten up there
will be more punishments
and they will be more severe and the
draft pick usually is what gets a team's
attention they don't like giving up
those
unscratched lottery tickets that can
become anything
they don't want to have those stripped
away from them
i don't know if his comments match the
headline and it was fair to devonta
adams he was asked
basically our you know are you the best
wide receiver in football
and he said yes and then he explained
why he thought he was
i have no problem with it it's like we
criticize the athlete when he doesn't
say anything and what he does say
we criticize him for saying something
devante adams
i don't know is he the best receiver if
i okay here's the question we had
earlier mike
you can have any receiver any receiver
for the next four years
the cost is the same who would you take
dk metcalf without question dk metcalf
that's who won the poll yeah yeah
without question but
i don't have a problem with devante
adams saying he thinks he's the best
receiver
because you need to believe that in
order to put that uniform on in order to
cross that thick white stripe and go on
to the field and accept the various
physical risks that you're taking
every time you play and to play at the
highest possible level you need to have
confidence that borders on delusion and
sometimes crosses over
into delusion i'm sure there are plenty
of receivers
not as good as devante adams or dk
metcalf that would say
yeah i think i'm the best you have to
think you're the best
and i think one of the key ingredients
dan for the best receivers that we see
now is not being a first-round draft
pick
because not being a first-round draft
pick lights a
fire under these guys devonta adams was
a second round
pick michael thomas who was motivated
unlike anyone else
at the position second round draft pick
saw receivers
that he looks at and says i'm better
than them go before him dk metcalf said
it yesterday
it was a blessing in disguise that he
wasn't a first-round pick because it
caused him to not take for granted the
opportunity in seattle
bust his ass and be who he is now should
that game have been played last night
well it depends on which team you ask
well the packers getting aaron jones
back certainly helped
but right i i just it felt
it was a bad look for the nfl in my
opinion
here's the problem when
the nfl has an opportunity to move
forward with a game
it is going to move forward with the
game because if you bump this game
to sunday monday or tuesday in order to
allow the 49ers to get back
trent williams who was removed from the
game because he
possibly was in sufficiently close
contact with kendrick bourne to end up
getting covet 19.
or brandon ayook first round draft pick
receiver who's done a great job for them
if you get those guys back
okay fine but the problem is between now
and sunday or monday or tuesday
the 49ers could find out that there are
other problems
and they could get to a point where you
can't play that game then what do you do
then that becomes the first game of the
18th week of the season that we believe
is inevitable
but they want to resist it as long as
they can so we saw this for the first
time dan
with the buccaneers raiders game they
went forward even though the raiders had
their starting offensive line
unavailable until
saturday or sunday morning i think it
was saturday morning they weren't
prepared
and they got blown out but the nfl got
to play the game
the nfl got to cash the check from the
networks i think that's a big
factor in all of this even though you
know you don't want to make it all about
money
they want to get these games in because
they want their money and
they got their money last night for
having the packers 49ers game on fox and
if you would delayed that game
there's no guarantee that you're going
to get that game in is that how it works
that
nbc will will write a check weekly to
the nfl
no no i bet no okay i was thinking wow
i'm just i'm
i'm making it as simple as possible and
as linear as possible and
it's probably not that way right if
games are ultimately lost
at a time when there are broader
negotiations happening with all the
networks
i don't know that there's a rebate per
se that would go back to the networks
but you avoid that conversation entirely
if you're the nfl
if you deliver all 256 games which they
have a strong motivation to do
i mentioned this yesterday there are two
things i know that are true in the nfl
i know that the kansas city chiefs are
the best team
right now and i know that the jets are
the worst team in the nfl
i i don't know much in between mike do
you have any definitives where you say
absolutely positively i know this no
it's great
and anytime you try to do that that's
when you find out that you know nothing
and i
i will agree that the chiefs
are on paper the best team
but i don't know what would happen if
you put the chiefs on the same field as
the steelers
right now okay because these dealers
have something
and dan i think it was born in last
year's adversity and the way they dealt
with not having ben roethlisberger and
had to have a couple of
what team did you grow up a fan of no no
i grew up 60 miles from pittsburgh but i
had to be different i had to be a
contrarian
so i didn't like the steelers i wish i
had it would have been great 70s for me
four super bowl trophies but i
i think that that i've i've been around
pittsburgh my entire life i know how
this team works and i think what they
went through last year planted the seeds
for this year because they have been
back
and they fight and they scratch and they
claw i watched that raven steelers game
back on monday
i don't know how the hell the steelers
won but you know what throw out all the
stats
only one matters points scored points
allowed and they keep finding a way to
do it so i feel like
if they played the chiefs right now
they'd find a way to outscore the chiefs
even if the chiefs would be going
up and down the field all day long with
patrick maybe yeah
i i i came into this season i said the
steelers are the most fascinating team
to me
because i thought they had everything
they just needed ben to be healthy and
ben has stayed healthy
and here they are undefeated uh your
good friend aaron rodgers in the last
two and a half years 75 touchdowns eight
interceptions
oh hey look i have become a tremendous
aaron rodgers fan and i think part of it
is hanging around chris sims every day
because
he regards aaron rodgers as the greatest
quarterback of all time
over his own father phil and
also i i think that he was done wrong
by the packers earlier this year which
makes him more sympathetic
i don't think they should have drafted a
quarterback they should have gotten him
help at receiver
and i think that makes these last years
of his in green bay however many there
will be
more compelling and it makes me want to
see him do well and i think he has
incredible physical gifts
and he's done more with limited talent
around him than i think
any quarterback has in recent memory so
yeah i think he's tremendous and last
night it was great to see what they were
able to do now it's hard to tell
against the 49ers b team but i like what
the packers have and i just wish he had
more help around him because he'd have a
better chance to add to his legacy
yeah and we look at these quarterbacks
you know drew brees is probably going to
end up with one super bowl
uh favre had won super bowl rogers may
end up with just one super bowl
what does that second super bowl mean do
you think the perception-wise of a
quarterback
well i don't know maybe we want to ask
jim plunkett that because he's got two
and he's never mentioned as a potential
hall-of-famer and he's got two
super bowl wins that he earned as the
quarterback of the raiders but i think
it does
start to separate you from the pack of
greats you know there's this echelon
of quarterbacks and tom brady has become
i think once he got to five
the guy that we would admit is the
greatest of all time at the position
once he gets to six
i think the debate ends but then you
start filling in under that and super
bowls
are part of it statistical achievement
longevity is part of it
there are different ways that you can
look at it brady was the first one to
unite
championships longevity and statistical
achievement
but yeah they look they all want as many
as they can
ben roethlisberger said before the
season dan he wants to win
super bowls he doesn't want just one
more he wants
two more or more than two more i mean
that's the way these guys are wired it's
the devante adams thing they all want to
be the best
every time they want to win every game
they want to win every championship and
it's got to torment them
if they only have one when their
otherwise great career ends
the dolphin situation with tua adam
schefter
reported that they basically this is a
10-game
trial for him because they have all
these draft picks including the texans
and that they might be in the market for
a quarterback which
all right it surprised me but it was
shefty reporting it
brian flores the dolphins coach comes
out and says you know we're not
doing this not that he would say yes we
are
doing this but what do you what do you
make of this situation with tuatanga
vialoa is he auditioning
to keep this job next year and dan look
i i i don't really think we need a
report
from anyone to lead us to the common
sensical conclusion
that when you are holding the houston
texans first round draft pick and they
currently are in the top
five in a field that's going to have
trevor lawrence and justin fields
you need to know what you have you need
to know what
tua is and look here's the reality
tuatangavi loa was an ownership pick
by the dolphins this year he wasn't a
coaching staff
gm who's the best guy what's our best
option the owner wants a franchise
quarterback
the bengals said no thank you when the
dolphins tried to trade up i still don't
know what the dolphins offered but the
bengals
said no so steven ross wants his
franchise quarterback they pick tua
over justin herbert may have been a
mistake based upon what we've seen from
herbert so far
the next 10 games will tell us but they
have to know what tua has
they have to see what tua can do because
maybe
there's going to be a josh rosen kyler
murray situation
for the dolphins next year and you only
know
whether or not to pursue that potential
franchise quarterback
by looking at what you have in the guy
that you think
could be your franchise quarterback and
dan look there's three types of teams in
the nfl
teams that have franchise quarterbacks
teams desperately looking for franchise
quarterbacks
and teams that have a guy that they're
not quite sure yet whether he is a
franchise quarterback
dolphins are in category number three
they need to know whether they're in
category one or category two
before they're on the clock with the
texans pick when april rolls around
i think it's a no-brainer that this is
what they're doing
because you want the guy that's going to
be your guy for the next 15 or 20 years
andrew siciliano tweeting mike mccarthy
still won't name a starting quarterback
for week nine for the cowboys
if you ran the cowboys right now what
would you do
well i would have signed colin
kaepernick a long time ago to be the
backup
to jack prescott frankly instead of andy
dalton
so if kaepernick were healthy he'd be
playing right now because prescott's not
available
but based on what i currently have
you just have to hope for the best
because it's not like you could sign a
guy and bring him in right now because
of the covet 19 protocols it's not like
you could have an emergency option today
and bring a guy in you're stuck with
garrett gilbert
or cooper rush you've decided ben
denucci is not the answer
and you just hope for the best and you
know jerry jones
i heard you last segment talking about
what the cowboys are doing
jerry jones has a couple of word salad
radio interviews every week on 105 3 the
fan in dallas
and it's a fascinating exercise in let's
figure out what
jerry is actually saying and a lot of
times you can't
but he talked about this concept of
possibly tanking and
he danced around it i mean look tanking
never happens from the perspective of
the player or the coach
although sometimes the coach is in on it
if he's got job security tanking happens
when you decide to see
what your third string quarterback can
do what your backup defensive back can
do
what your backup offensive lineman can
do and then it just kind of takes its
course
and if you're the cowboys right now and
you know it's done and you know and you
look it's just done if you're watching
the cowboys it's done yeah they could
still win the division okay fine
it's done for the cowboys this year once
you know it's done
you win by losing you gain
in the draft order by plummeting in the
standings
and the nfl never talks about that
because they don't want to legitimize it
but i think jerry jones is smart enough
to know
he's got one of these weird years where
the team's going belly up the last time
they had a year like this they got
ezekiel
they may get somebody great this year
and wouldn't that be something
if the cowboys are in position to decide
do we take trevor lawrence
do we take justin fields or do we pay
dak prescott 37 million dollars
for one more year in 2021 if i said you
could have dac
or justin fields i'd take dak because we
don't know what justin fields is going
to be
we just don't know i don't want to spend
37 million dollars
well that's a different issue you didn't
tell me what i'm going to pay down no
i want right do i want the cowboys
situation right now
given the way they've mismanaged it for
the last two years and not paid back the
moment that the window opened on a
second contract i don't want that
situation
because here's the thing 37 million is
just the starting point
i can't tag him in 2022 because he gets
a 44
raise over 37 million that's 54 million
in 2022. so i can't do that i'm taking
justin fields
under that scenario but you always take
the proven guy over the unproven guy
if you have the cap space in the cash to
pay the proven guy
always great to talk to you we
appreciate your time have a great
weekend mike all right dan you too pal
that's mike florio
pro football talk bro footballtalk.com
pro football talk live with chris sims
preceding this show on peacock